le président du modem maire de boué haut
commissaire au plan françois bayrou
bonsoir bonsoir merci beaucoup d'avoir
accepté notre invitation
beaucoup de sujets à évoquer avec vous
dans la demi heure qui vient d'abord la
question dans certains remaniements on a
compris que le président et la première
ministre y travaillaient ce matin à la
mi-journée sur lci la présidente du
groupe renaissance à l'assemblée
nationale or berger disait que c'était
dans les heures qui viennent les
prochaines heures est-ce que vous pouvez
nous confirmer ce timing donc ça dépend
ce qu'on veut on vient de faire sans
mais les prochaines heures parce que
c'est probablement dans les prochaines
heures
et dans les jours prochains voilà je moi
je ne suis pas dans le secret des dates
je sais qu'ils y travaillent et donc on
voit bien qu'il y à une période assez
courte entre la décision et la
déclaration de politique générale ou que
la première ministre fera devant
l'assemblée nationale ce sera bien avant
mercredi avant le discours de politique
générale oui on pourrait imaginer
beaucoup de stratégie parce que vous
savez il ya des ya des petits secrets
comme ça qui sont difficiles à
comprendre et et à saisir
les ministres sont qui viennent d'être
élus sont en même temps député
or comme vous savez on peut pas être les
2 en même temps et donc les ministres
lorsqu'ils sont aux gouvernements ne
peuvent plus voter pendant un mois à
l'assemblée nationale lors si par hasard
on avait besoin de leurs votes on
pourrait peut-être imaginer qu'il y ait
un chevauchement mais je ne suis pas
étonné en deux temps bonjour je n'ai pas
partagé la réponse à ce que vous dites
que vous n'êtes pas dans le secret des
dieux mais j'imagine que vous avez été
consultés et j'imagine qu'en tant que
partenaire président d'un des principaux
partis de la majorité vous disputez est
ce que par exemple vous souhaitez dans
cette nouvelle équipe il y ait une
grande représentation du modem on
rappelle que vous avez aujourd'hui marc
fesneau ministre de l'agriculture une
souveraineté alimentaire et la
secrétaire et à justine bénin mais
qu'elle a été battue et qui va devoir
quitter gouvernement vous soyez surpris
si je vous disais non non mais je
préfère vous l'entendre dire c'est la
mer 10 ans et plus alors qu'à mal
devient je pense que la composition du
gouvernement obéit à un certain nombre
de principes d'un de ces principes c'est
l' équilibre
entre les forces qui soutiennent le
gouvernement je ne dis pas la
proportionnelle stricte je n'évoque
jamais des idées de de chantage de deux
bras de fer tout ça est ridicule ça
appartient des républiques passé mais si
les choses sont bien faites il doit y
avoir un équilibre et chacun doit
retrouver une part de son soutien dans
le déploiement de l'action c'est logique
c'est simple et j'imagine que c'est le
but que tout le monde 2e doit atteindre
en tout cas bien sûr je suis là pour
éveiller et physique est attentif alors
je le disais à l'instant dans les
problématiques qui se posent au présent
la république à la première ministre il
ya d'abord le remplacement de nice qui
ont été battus aux législatives y en a
trois qui sont dans ce cas là c'est le
cas d'amélie montchanin de brigitte
bourguignon de justine bénin et puis
elle cas de la nouvelle présidente de
l'assemblée nationale il ya une grande
pie v qui a d'ores et déjà quitté le
gouvernement est-ce que là quand on dit
remaniement françois bayrou on parle du
remplacement de ces quatre femmes là
point où est ce qu'on parle du
remplacement de ces quatre femmes là et
la constitution d'une équipe renouvelée
différente plus adaptée aux
circonstances
c'est une page nouvelle qui s'ouvre
c'est bien que tout le monde voit ça
comme la continuation des pages
précédentes
et cet entre deux des élections étaient
un peu comme ça sibylline de ce point de
vue là non je pense que c'est une page
nouvelle qui s'ouvre et je pense que le
président de la république et la
première ministre vont en profiter pour
donner une coloration à leur
gouvernement parce qu'il ya vous le
savez des postes qu'ils n'étaient pas
pourvues il ya des postes qui vont être
abandonnées il ya des postes qu'ils
n'étaient pas pourvus les transports le
logement est donc évidemment y aura une
coloration du gouvernement un peu
différente et j'espère eu une énergie
parce que ce dont on ne se rend pas
compte c'est que les questions qui vont
être devant nous aujourd'hui en france
en europe et dans le monde sont les
questions les plus graves que nous ayons
rencontrée depuis cinq ans les détails
radiologiquement ce que vous avez c'est
un contexte très particulier juste vous
dites une coloration qu'est ce que vous
entendez par une coloration à quelles
conditions ce remaniement sera t-il
réussi à vos yeux je ne pose pas de
conditions aux formations de
gouvernement je sais ce que je pense je
pense que il
est bon qu'il y ait des personnalités
politiques je déjà et expliquer ça
plusieurs fois c'est à dire des
des personnalités qui ont en tête que
les problèmes du pays ne se découpe pas
dossier par dossier
la réponse est pas dans le dossier la
réponse est dans l'énergie la capacité
d'entraînement
la puissance nécessaire pour s'adresser
au pays le faire adhérer à un effort qui
va être considérable considérable
et ça c'est cette faculté d'entraînement
qui est le devoir politique du
gouvernement quand les hommes politiques
jusqu'en quand il faut beau permettez
moi jusque les rameaux je pense aux qui
fait aussi ne jamais perdre de vue le
l'objectif d'élargissement politique
pour le couvrir donc alors reprenons ce
que vous venez dire quand vous dites un
gréement plus politique est ce que ça
veut dire avec des personnalités ayant
une expérience d'élus locaux par exemple
est ce que ce sont des personnes qui en
ont une un logiciel particulier à quoi
ça tient à ce que ça tient au parcours
où est ce que ça tient à la personnalité
la vocation politique
ce n'est pas seulement la capacité
d'analysé sujet par sujet la situation
du pays et pas seulement
constituèrent dossier la vocation
politique c'est s'interroger sur les
raisons profondes
qui font qu un pays comme le nôtre est
dans une crise aussi grave que celle que
nous rencontrons qu'est ce qui fait
que par exemple aujourd'hui
tout le monde le note il ya dans la
société française
une espèce de
d'abandon pour beaucoup et pour
principalement ou assez souvent dans les
jeunes générations
l'abandon du désir d'un certain type de
travail pourquoi est ce qu'il y a des
centaines de milliers d'entreprises qui
ne trouvent pas dans un pays où il ya
pourtant temps de chômer ça on y répond
en fonction qui en mai au gouvernement
oui en tout cas il faut au gouvernement
d
des personnalités ayant comme ça une
faculté ayant des enquêtes approche
ayant une flamme pour prôner une fois
juste que je m y est comme si on venait
voit que par exemple mise de l'éducation
pap ndiaye il vient la société civile et
il a fait son entrée en politique à
l'occasion de son entrée au gouvernement
bon on peut pas dire qu'il a commis de
faux pas jusqu'ici parce qu'il ne sait
encore rien passé dans son ministère
est-ce qu'il a le profil dans la période
actuelle quelles que soient ses qualités
intellectuelles son parcours le fait que
ce soit certainement un homme brillant
est-ce qu'il était armé pour faire face
à ceux qui arrivent le qui par exemple a
jamais mis un pied à l'assemblée
jusqu'ici
c'est pas l'essentiel pap n'diaye ça
n'est pas un technicien de l'éducation
il est pas dans les innombrables
fonction répartie réseau existant dans
d'habitude et des habitudes décennale
dans le monde de l'éducation moi je met
de l'espoir en lui
et pourtant vous connaissez ma
sensibilité vous avez été misés
l'éducation j'ai été mis en location
longtemps et ma sensibilité c'est celle
c'est la sensibilité républicaine du
retour le plus rapide possible et le
plus important possible aux fondamentaux
à ce qui va donner à chacun des élèves
la liberté de juger la liberté de pensée
la liberté de s'exprimer et la liberté
de juger mais pas bouteille il a un
parcours personnel qui est ok je suis
extrêmement sensible
il vient et vient pas des milieux de
pouvoir vient pas des milieux
privilégiez il vient pas des milieux de
ce que les concours
de l'administration habitué depuis
toujours à se dire qu'il serait un jour
chef de quelque chose c'est pas du tout
son profil son profil est un profil
universitaire et avec le parcours qui
est le sien seront son origine familiale
le la province le avec le parcours qui
est le sien et la remarquable réussite
académique qui est la sienne il peut
être moi je crois qu'il peut comprendre
vous comprenez je m'exprimais en parlant
des antennes je pense que c'est
quelqu'un alors il a eu beaucoup de
polémiques autour de sa nomination on
l'a accusé d'être rookies de
moi je crois pas du tout ça je ne pense
pas qu'avec son parcours il puisse ne
pas être républicain autrement dit
l'idée 2 et donc il pourra s d de
l'universalisme républicain
l'idée que l'éducation s'adresse à tout
le monde pour le faire monter le plus
haut possible et pas pour découper la
société en un groupe qui seraient
indépendants les uns des autres et donc
moi je met de l'espoir en lui
alors on verra si c'est justifié bien
sûr mais en tout cas pour vous il peut
avoir les qualités pour le poste quand
je disais à l'instant la politique le
parcours politique ya des noms d'élus
locaux qui ont circulé ces derniers
jours alors c'est toujours très
hasardeux de citer des noms avant
remaniement mais par exemple présent la
région grand test jean rottner crise
tellement ans est président de la région
pays de la loire gilles averous par
exemple qui est le maire de châteauroux
qui sont les trois la gauche de l'écran
sur la photo qu'on voit qu'ils ont tous
les trois appelés à bâtir un accord de
gouvernement avec emmanuel macron et on
a même entendu également le nom du
député lr philippe juvin il se trouve
que les quatre ans que je viens de citer
ont justement la caractéristique des
tous les quatre issues de l herbe disiez
tout à l'heure il faut continuer
d'élargir est ce que par exemple aller
chercher dans ce type de profil chez à
l'ère des élus locaux pour certains
d'entre eux ce serait une bonne piste
des élus qui ont l'intention de
participer à l'oeuvre de reconstruction
on a deux reconstructions ou deux
raisons de reconstruire la première
raison il ya trente ans que dérive
nos institutions et notre manière de
gouverner 30 ans au moins
30 ans et il y as deuxièmement les
crises successives que nous venons de
rencontrer le coc vide les gilets jaunes
dans l'ordre les gilet jaune en plus que
vides et puis la guerre avec les
désastres économiques qui sont tant
qu'ils sont en gestation ça fait deux
grands chapitres qui oblige à la
reconstruction et que tout ça était
participer ou que de nombreuses et du
deuil qui participe et je trouve ça très
bien je vais même aller beaucoup plus
loin
je pense depuis longtemps que dans une
situation comme ça comme celle là nous
sommes coresponsables de l'avenir pas
seulement la majorité joue partis
politiques confondus tous les partis
politiques majorité et opposition sont
co responsables de l'avenir et s'il y en
a un certain nombre qui ont eux se
présentent comme étant uniquement
négatif uniquement d'instructeurs
uniquement critique il manque aux deux
voix vous dit que le dépassement
nullement de moi ni mes livres
d'espacement politique à condition aussi
qu'il ne soit pas seulement de façade
que ça ne soit pas un habillage ce qui
veut dire qu'il faut que du point de vue
politique aussi le gouvernement
se se sentent se vivent en situation de
construction de quelque chose de
totalement inédit l'époque dans laquelle
nous entrons et sans exemple dans les
décennies que nous venons blé françois
bayrou a vu ce que vous décrivez des
circonstances des profils les qualités
nécessaires on se dit que le banc de
touche pour emmanuel macron et pas
infinies on a du mal à faire une longue
liste de personnalités est-ce que vous
par exemple le temps n'est pas venu pour
vous de revenir au classement vous
l'avez été au début du premier courrier
mais je ne je ne suis pas je ne suis pas
en situation de faire ça c'est pas mon
idée j'ai la responsabilité de ce qu'on
appelle le plan je pense que ça peut
être très utile dans la période qui
vient en tant que haut commissaire au
plan notamment 6 on prend au sérieux
cet idéal de refondation que le
président de la république a exprimé que
ça veut dire la refondation ça veut dire
à peu près exactement ce que je viens
d'énoncer devant vous c'est à dire on a
des problèmes qu'on en a jamais eu
devant ces problèmes on reste très
souvent avec les logiciels anciens pour
et contre gauche droite ce qui est à mon
sens aujourd'hui tellement loin de de la
réalité est là c'est ce qu'on a bien
compris et donc et puis avec les
logiciels classiques des des fonctions
dans le jeu démocratique juste dans un
discours partis associations groupes de
pression si on prend au sérieux
l'idéal que le président de la
république a exprimé c'est à dire d'un
partage en tout entre toutes les forces
qui font la démocratie française
démocratie politique démocratie sociale
démocratie d'opinion démocratie
deux associations se tient si on prend
au sérieux de cet idéal là alors c'est
une oeuvre qui vaut la peine elle est
très difficile et ça je veux bien je
veux bien aidé vous dites je ne suis pas
en situation est ce que votre point de
vue le fait que vous ayez été mis en
examen dans la sphère des assistants
parlementaires du modem au parlement
européen reste un handicap pour le cieux
je vais vous dire quelque chose cette
affaire est parti depuis plus de cinq
ans oui et elle n'a pas avancé et elle
n'a pas avancé et moi je vous dit les
yeux dans les yeux
en toute franchise comme c'est le nom de
votre émission je vous dis c'est une
affaire dans laquelle il n'y a rien et
on a maintenant des décisions de justice
pour le montrer
alors on peut la faire traîner des
années ça c'est possible mais il n'y a
rien de moralement répréhensible et rien
qui était effet
et je m'engage en vous le disons alors
ça peut traîner on peut aussi tenir les
gens c'est dur effectivement à bout de
gaffe dans ce remaniement françois
bayrou il ya aussi des caps
l épine c'est le cas par exemple du
ministre actuel des solidarités damien
abad une enquête a été ouverte mardi
pour tentative de viol après qu'une
plainte a été déposée il ya eu plusieurs
accusations conques est relié par la
presse le ministre dément est-ce qu'il
doit rester au gouvernement au nom de la
présomption d'innocence ou est ce que
c'est la parole des femmes la libération
de la parole des femmes qui doit primer
ni l'un ni l'autre mon point de vue
n'est pas celui-là je vous souvenez que
j'ai moi-même de ma propre volonté avec
marielle de sarnez qui était à l'époque
ministre des affaires européennes nous
avons quitté le gouvernement on n'était
pas mis en examen non
il y avait à peine une enquête
préliminaire
qui est vous voyez à quel point tout ça
a été orchestré tout à fait par hasard
naturel et moi vous savez bien que dans
la jungle et références dans la vie
politique il ya absolument jamais de
traquenards et de pièges ce sont des ce
sont des âmes trop noble pour se livrer
à sa b2 les sons que les actifs en
france oui
et pourquoi avons-nous quitter le
gouvernement pas du tout parce que nous
étions coupables il sera prouvé que nous
ne l'étions pas
bien que ça dure des années
uniquement pour une raison c'est quand
vous êtes l'objet d'accusations qui sont
comme ça brutale violente entretenu vous
ne pouvez plus exercer votre fonction
sereinement j'étais ministre de la
justice vous rendez compte des vous
rendez compte des difficultés qu aurait
eu un ministre de la justice dans ces
sites l'afrique est damien abad
aujourd'hui et je pense que dans la
réflexion qui doit être la sienne et
celle du de la première ministre et
celle du président de la république 7
cette question de la
la capacité à exercer pleinement sa
fonction
lorsqu'on est l'objet d'accusations même
injuste ça doit évidemment participer à
la réflexion est ce que ça vaut
également pour la secrétaire d'état
crise aulas zacharopoulos qui l a été
visé par des plaintes même chose pour
viol ou pour violence mais dans le cadre
cette fête sa pratique de j colloques et
sa lancée
je m'avance parce que je connais pas le
dossier
je n'ai que deux l'estiment pour crise
ou d'un accord au boulot
qui était député européenne que tout à
fait avant d'entraîner si on se met
maintenant en france a accusé de viol de
deux gestes je ne sais quoi la
concurrence y est effectivement des
plaintes pour la gynécologue comment
voulez vous faire un examen
gynécologique et d'ailleurs
l'association de tous les gynécologues
français s'est exprimé c'est réunis
s'est exprimé en disant nous sommes à
tout instant menacé de ce genre de drame
un examen gynécologique implique en
effet que le médecin soit avec sa
patiente dans un dans un rapport de 2
d'observation
comment va-t-on faire et est-ce qu'on va
pénaliser criminaliser absolument tous
les gestes qui sont de cet ordre-là
savez il ya eu des drames ait eu des
morts autour de ça donc je suis pour que
sauf si j'ignore des aspects de ces
choses mais j'ai mais j'ai parlé à
madame ça car au boulot je suis pour que
on arrête les les dérives obsessionnel
dans laquelle on se sent en fait engagé
par exemple montérégie l'écho d'un
damien bas légine et que cela était en
cours les gynécologues
sont elles menacées de ne plus pouvoir
exercer leur métier vous rendez compte
dans quel genre de de folie on est
s'il n'y a pas autre chose mais comment
y aurait-il autre chose et donc il ya là
quelque chose que quand effet je trouve
dangereux et risqué et je ne mets pas
tous sur le même plan il ya quelques
temps et vous l'avez rappelé en début
d'émission vous aviez dit il faut une
équipe politique ça passait dans votre
esprit y compris par matignon et par le
ou la première ministre et les avait
deux bornes dit ne pas s'être senti visé
par cette critique elle a quand même
précisé vous étiez expliqué qu'elle vous
avez reçu à matignon qu'est ce qu'il y
avait besoin d'expliquer françois bayrou
non mais le son confrère on perd on peut
interpréter cette cette déclaration que
je viens encore de défendre devant vous
comme une attaque ad hominem comme une
attaque personnelle contre
la première minute c'était absolument
pas le cas et je le lui ai dit et je
pense qu'elle clame conflit nous ne
sommes pas dans des circonstances
ordinaires
ça n'est pas un gouvernement ordinaire
après une élection ordinaire et après
une réélection ordinaire on est dans la
période la plus risquée la plus critique
la plus porteuse de menaces
que notre pays ait connu à mon sens
depuis la guerre
parce que à la fois les obstacles qui
sont devant nous les orages qui viennent
les ouragans qui nous menace sont de
dimensions jamais connu récemment et en
même temps notre pays est dans un état
de profond de fissures fracture j'avais
envie de dire délabrement il ya des
secteurs entiers qui ne retrouvent plus
leurs repères c'est vrai dans la santé
c'est vrai dans l'éducation c'est vrai
dans notre démocratie c'est vrai dans la
manière dont se conduisent les élus
c'est vrai dans la violence que la
société exprime ses vraies dents dans
une sécession d'une partie du pays qui a
entraîné l'abstention parce que vous
êtes réconcilier avec elisabeth derniers
jours nous avons jamais été fâché est-ce
que vous pouvez comprendre qu'on puisse
sans notation personnelle essayer de
faire entendre et de faire triompher si
possible une vision de la situation il
ne s'agit pas des questions de je
préfère un tel le pinceau qu'une telle
il ya toujours des questions de
personnes en politique mais ça n'est pas
des questions de préférence personnelle
ce sont des questions lourdes mentaux
liés à la hauteur des circonstances
cette semaine la première ministre en
l'occurrence elisabeth banques donc va
prononcer un discours de politique
générale en prénationale à priori
mercredi en tout cas c'est le timing
qu'on a en tête vous confirmez ce timing
je ne suis pas sevré depuis bon vous
avez pas eu la confirmation notre côté
mais vous ne démentait pas il ya une
question qui va se poser on va venir au
fond dans un instant vous l'avez déjà
largement évoqué les circonstances elle
ce qu'elle doit se soumettre à un vote
de confiance à cette occasion là bien c
est qu elle avait le choix pour les
premiers ministres n'ont pas eu la même
attitude sauf que ça donnera une
coloration connotation différente à son
début d'action
on lit des analyses différentes moi j'ai
le souvenir par exemple de michel rocard
oui michel rocard n'avait pas la
majorité on l'a placé pour le savoir
parce que on l'aidait quand il fallait
nous le le groupe centriste indépendant
de l'époque on l'aider quand il fallait
j'étais un tout jeune député mais je
m'en souviens très bien
et il sait pas soumis à un vote de
confiance pourquoi parce que quand vous
vous soumettez à un vote de confiance
vous avez le risque limité je crois que
l'assemblée vote la défiance auquel cas
le gouvernement est par terre ça n'est
pas la principale raison la principale
raison c'est que quand vous soumettez un
vote de confiance les oppositions
critiques vont scruter pour savoir qui
en s'abstenant vous allez c'est obtenir
la confiance l'occurrence par exemple
une abstention des républicains ou de
rassemblement national par exemple
et donc vous voyez toutes les
interprétations et vous voyez que les
oppositions qui auraient envie de
s'abstenir elles craignent d'être taxé
de complicité
j'ai souvent expliqué il ya il ya une
une des innombrables loi de bayrou dans
dans cette affaire là une abstention
quand vous êtes dans la majorité c'est
un vote contre quand vous êtes dans
l'opposition sans vote pour
vous faites un pas dans une direction
qui normalement dès pâle à volants vous
dites il faut pas se mettre dans cette
situation moi je dis que je comprends
très bien michel rocard qui ne l'a pas
fait je crois
pierre mauroy qui ne m'a pas fait il
yad'autres premier ministre je suis pas
sûr que au début de la vème république
cet effet c'est une habitude qui a été
prise ne sera pas celle des autres
agences être utile mais moi je comprends
très bien le refus des interprétations
et donc je suis plutôt
pour que la première ministre et le
président réfléchissent ensemble à ce
sujet ça aurait naturellement
le sens d'un défi politique dans ma nage
politique mais il ya aussi des risques
pour les pour les oppositions alors vous
rappeler les circonstances
exceptionnelles dans lesquelles en est
on a bien vu que le présent la
république s il ya aussi donner des
réponses différentes il a évoqué
quelques semaines le cener le conseil
national de la fondation c'était avant
l'assemblée soit l'élu par les élections
législatives mais on n'entend l'idée
qu'il pourrait revenir ce ses nerfs
comme une chambre de discussions pour
préparer la loi avant qu'elle soit
présenté au conseil des ministres comme
une concertation préalable est ce que
c'est une idée de votre point de vue qui
aurait dû changer ou est-ce qu'on doit
assumer de laisser l'assemblée discuter
amender la loi le lieu où se discute ous
amende et/ou ce vote la loi c'est le
parlement dans ses deux chambres
je répète qu'en plus il ya un conseil
économique et social mais le président
de la république a une idée ou une
intuition va dire ça qu'il a depuis
longtemps
g j'ai beaucoup beaucoup parlé de ce
sujet avec lui je sais ce qu est ce qu
est dans son esprit dans son esprit il
ya que nos institutions
ont probablement acquis un caractère
trop routinier
qu' on ne les entend plus que peut-être
et qu elle peut être n'entendent pas
parfaitement le pays regardez à quel
point les débats qu'on a sont ridicules
vous avez vu les pensées à quoi alléger
les débats sur l'attribution des postes
à l'assemblée nationale les indigents
disant vous avez été trop indulgent avec
le front national dans nos
téléspectateurs ce que vous vous évoquez
c'est le fait que leur assemblée
nationale a eu cette semaine des
vice-présidences à l'assemblée nationale
pour la première l'histoire grâce à la
porte vote de la majorité présidente a
seulement entre autres parce que les
accusations vous étiez des accusations
sur la place qui a été fait au front
national il ya des accusations
symétrique sur la place qui est faite à
la nuit pas désuni tellement panique à
qui on a donné on a donné entre
guillemets disent les opposants disent
les critiques une place excessive en
acceptant quelques leurs représentants
devienne président de la commission des
finances mais on comprend rien donc vous
dites tout cela s'est il produit par des
vice présidences et c'était le rôle de
la noce d'avoir là bas ça comme ça
maintenant on ne comprend rien à
l'institution parlementaire dans
l'institution parlementaire se sait le
nombre de vos élus qui vous donnent à la
proportionnelle des responsabilités dans
l'assemblée tous les postes y en a des
dizaines enfin en tout cas vingtaine une
vingtaine tous les postes clés sont
codifiés et attribuer un nombre de
points vous avez un portefeuille de
points en fonction de vos députés 90
députés pour le front national sans
[Musique]
contribuer
j'entends bien cette antienne est ce que
vous avez entendu ce que j'ai dit bien
sûr mais je vois que certains lycées y
compris la majorité ce qu'on voulait
bien écoutez c'est automatique
vous avez droit à un certain nombre vous
avez un certain nombre d'élus vous avez
droit à un certain nombre de points qui
vous donne droit à un certain nombre de
postes et c'est bien normal je vais pas
moi qui ai défendu la démocratie sous
toutes ses formes depuis des années au
point de proposer une banque de la
démocratie la proportionnelle dans
toutes les élections et puis deux et
puis les signatures pour l'élection
présidentielle je vais pas venir vous
dire qu'il faut traiter les élus
différemment selon leur étiquette quand
vous êtes élu vous être présent c'est de
la blague récente des démocraties et
donc c'est le respect strict des règles
démocratiques qui permettent de vivre en
france un débat apaisé sans ça c'est
dans la rue que ça se traite vous avez
évoqué le cas d'eric coquerel le nouveau
présent la commission des finances
député de la france insoumise tu seras
un instant la question politique il ya
des accusations qui ont été portées
contre lui cette semaine d'abord par
l'essayiste et militante féministe
rokhaya diallo puis un signalement fait
auprès d'une commission interne de la
france insoumise sur des comportements
potentiellement inapproprié en direction
des femmes est-ce que de votre point de
vue ça remet en cause sa place à la tête
de la commission des finances je ne
connais rien à cette affaire je n'ai
aucun élément de ces accusations
monsieur coquerelles et 1 et participe
du débat public je l' ai pas rencontrés
souvent je n'ai aucune information est
donc ce n'est pas à moi de m'exprimer
sur ce sujet d'un point de vue politique
la présidence de la commission des
finances l'avait rappelé l'idée que ce
soit un élu de la france en sont mises
ça a fait pour le coup l'objet de ces
inquiétudes dans votre camp il ya la
question maintenant c'est vrai dans mon
corps dans les milieux économiques dans
la majorité on va dire cela mais
seulement est ce qu'il faut le craindre
ou est ce que vous dites non en prison
de la commission des finances fera son
travail comme n'importe quel autre quel
que soit son bord politique président de
la commission des finances il est
responsable parce que plusieurs des
commissions des finances a beaucoup de
pouvoir et il peut assez facilement
bloquer un débat ou en tout cas
augmenter le risque de blocage d'un
débat il ya beaucoup d'artifices dans le
dans la manière dans les assemblées
fonctionne et donc j'espère moi qu'il y
aura sur tous les bancs ceux de la
france a soumis ceux du rassemblement
national ceux d opposition - moins
extrêmes et ceux de la majorité qui a
son rôle aussi j'espère qu'il y aura une
attitude responsable j'espère que tout
le monde va seront dans le compte
il ya des moments dans l'histoire des
peuples ou si on continue la routine des
a priori et des simplismes on est on
trahit l'intérêt général c'est un moment
comme celui là que nous sommes en train
de vivre les salles de ciseaux oui qu'il
faudra aussi que la majorité accepte de
faire des concessions à ses oppositions
qu'elle donne des gages qu'elle fasse
débat s'est même pas donné des gages il
faut que tout le monde accepte les
règles du de la vie parlementaire qui
font qu on confronte des opinions et
qu'on accepte de débattre ensemble y
compris en changeant les textes mais par
exemple pourquoi la nécessité de d'une
démarche politique
quand vous êtes au gouvernement ou
responsable à l'assemblée nationale est
si vive est si forte les parents quand
la gauche vous dira à l'assemblée afin
tirao aux députés à l'assemblée on veut
le smic à 1500 euros on veut une baisse
des taxes sur le carburant est ce que
vous direz je goûte l'air je parlais de
responsabilité est ce que ce sont des
choix responsables parce que ça coûtera
trop finances publiques parce que mon
entreprise est en situation de
déséquilibre est la première chose qu'il
faudrait se fixer comme objectif c'est
que
ce pays que dont nous avons la charge et
qui a confié les mandats que ce pays se
remettre à produire se remette à créer
des richesses parce qu'il s'agit pas
seulement de distribuer vous distribuez
quoi vous distribuez comme on disait
autrefois de la monnaie de singe des
chèques en blanc essais et cette idée de
d'un pays dans lequel il n'aurait plus
qu'une seule question c'est distribué
est à mon sens un élément du
déséquilibre nationale vendre un fait
les gens n'ont pas de vie votre entendu
il faut toujours faire si vous en faites
pas vous dans votre alors foyer siméant
vos chaînes il se trouve que vu l'état
de la situation de pouvoir d'achat les
français on voit mal où vont être les
sources d'économies dans les semaines à
venir eh bien je suis persuadé qu'il y
en a pas ce que la première source de
rééquilibrage s'est pas seulement les
économies c'est que tout d'un coup
l'action de l'état des pouvoirs publics
d'aidé de la puissance publique se met à
être utile au service du pays de la
société se met à aider plutôt qu'à
freiner se mettent à soutenir les
sources d'innovations qui existait deux
et de prise de conscience qui existe
c'est un changement des relations
nécessaires entre ce qu'est puissance
publique et ce qu'est la société le
drame convient et vous le savez bien
c'est que la société a le sentiment que
la puissance publique les autorités
publiques lui sont totalement étrangères
que ils sont là pour faire appliquer un
certain nombre de règles et de normes
aveuglément alors qu'il faut au
contraire que désormais
il faudrait que désormais toute la
société se sentent soutenus par ce que
nous avons construit ensemble et vous
voyez à quel point il s'agit de deux de
réformes profondes et de prise de
conscience profonde merci beaucoup
françois bayrou d'avoir été notre invité
est d'être venu faire le pari de la
raison elle a entendu puisque c'était un
appel à la raison si ce soit cet
entretien avec vous à l'enthousiaste à
l'enthousiasmé et à l'engagement bon on
va vers déjà dans les prochaines heures
et les prochains jours si vous êtes
appelés entendu par la majorité les
oppositions